[Musik]
für die muffins braucht ihr 12 oder
kekse 150 gramm zucker eine prise salz
160 gramm mehl 40 gramm kakaopulver und
viertel teelöffel natron einen halben
teelöffel backpulver zweier 60
milliliter buttermilch und 150
milliliter speise irgendwo in dem jetzt
einfach die kekse und die werden jetzt
auch noch ein kleiner
ich mache das jetzt in einem
gefrierbeutel und kann jetzt hier in
einer rührschüssel die trockenen zutaten
verrühren jetzt kommen die flüssigen
zutaten rein und dies werden die zutaten
einfach noch kurz verrührt und wer
möchte kann jetzt noch ein bisschen
nespresso dazu geben
das mache ich jetzt auch einfach für
einen leckeren geschmack und jetzt
nämlich den teig und portionieren mit
einem iphone ehre in die zwölf muffin
förmchen
es gebe ich die himbeere in einem topf
dann etwas zitronensaft etwas wasser zum
einkochen und puderzucker die himbeeren
sie netz eingekocht und jetzt werde ich
hier durch ein sieb streichen während es
jetzt noch abtropfen ich stelle mal kurz
zur seite und streiks leichtfertig kann
ich hier in einem topf schon mal isomalt
schmelzen das flüssige glas also dass
isomalt hier drauf damit als eine platte
fest werden kann
und jetzt kann ich noch die sahne
unterheben und jetzt werden die cupcakes
damit bespritzt jetzt darüber fließen
lassen
[Musik]
jetzt können diese entweder so lassen
oder ihr steckt jetzt hier die
glassplitter rein oder nehmen zum
beispiel so eine dekoration finde ich
auch ganz hübsch vor allem die messer
und die mumien und auch die gespenster
und geister passen wirklich super dazu
[Musik]
für den teig verwende ich 450 gramm mehl
einen teelöffel zucker einen teelöffel
salz drei teelöffel kokosöl 225 gramm
eiskalte butter 60 milliliter eiskaltes
wasser und zwei teelöffel zitronensaft
ich stelle jetzt den teig her und da ist
ganz wichtig dass alle zutaten sehr kalt
sind ich stelle auch die butter immer
für eine halbe stunde in den
gefrierschrank so ist sie wirklich
eiskalt und auch das wasser ist eiskalt
jetzt kommt das kokosöl rein die butter
ein stückchen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt das eiskalte wasser dazu und
noch der zitronensaft und davon zwei
teelöffel den teig nehme ich jetzt und
gebe ihnen hier auf die arbeitsfläche
und danach muss ich ihnen für zwei
stunden kühl und die zeit kann ich dann
ganz gut nutzen um die füllung
vorzubereiten
für die füllung verwende ich 150 gramm
braunen zucker 200 milliliter kirschsaft
200 gramm äpfel 250 gramm hokkaido
kürbis 250 gramm kirschen aus dem glas
einen teelöffel zitronensaft etwas bei
den extrakt eine prise salz und hier
noch die gewürze muskatnuss zimt und
ingwer zwei teelöffel stärke und zwei
esslöffel wasser
[Musik]
den hokkaido kürbis finde ich ganz
praktisch weil man ähnliche schälen muss
also da wird die schale auch richtig
schön weich und ich brauche davon jetzt
nur 250 gramm
jetzt gehts direkt ans verarbeiten der
füllung es gebe es zuerst den braunen
zucker in einen topf und lass ihn darin
karamellisieren
und zwar presse jetzt direkt auch den
zitronensaft zu den äpfeln und zum
kürbis dazu dann kommen da die gewürze
mit rein ingwer zimt ein bisschen salz
und muskatnuss frisch gerieben
die kirchen die kann ich auch schon
einrühren jetzt kommt hier das ganze
obst mit rein mit dem kürbis jetzt ist
derzeit gut durch gekühlt und ich habe
ihn jetzt auch schon mal gut
durchgeknetet ich habe zur tat formung
mit hebe boden damit ich einfach später
die tat oder gut raus bekommen und jetzt
könnt ihr hier die gesichter rein machen
und zwar nehme ich jetzt dafür einfach
noch töne und kleine ausstecher und
damit könnt ihr zum beispiel gespenster
gesichter machen oder kürbisse oder auch
einen totenkopf mit nämlich die
abgekühlte schulung und die kommt jetzt
einfach mitten rein und jetzt können sie
schon in den backofen
[Musik]
für den hefeteig brauche ich einen
würfel hefe 200 millimeter warmes wasser
30 gramm zucker 30 gramm honig etwas
schwarze lebensmittel verpasste 260
gramm butter milch zweier vier teelöffel
salz 160 gramm flüssige butter und ein
kilo mehl zuerst er sich jetzt die hefe
im wasser auf und füge den zucker den
honig und ein bisschen lebensmittel
verpasst hinzu jetzt kommen noch die
übrigen zutaten also butter milch eier
salz mehl und butter mit dazu also
momentan sieht das ganze noch ein
bisschen abgefahren aus ich zeige euch
den teig zu einer kugel verwende ich
jetzt nicht mehr so viel mehr legt die
kugel hinein und väter auch die
oberfläche damit sie nicht trocknet und
kann jetzt in teig abdecken und für eine
stunde ruhen lassen
den gut aufgegangen trainiere ich jetzt
in 80 gramm schwere teiglinge und die
form ich dann mit den händen so richtig
schönen glatten kugeln und nach dem
backen werden sie direkt mit flüssiger
butter bestrichen
die bürger wahnsinn jetzt fertig sind
auch schon abgekühlt und sehen richtig
gut aus ich freue mich schon richtig auf
den burger
jetzt werde ich noch die restlichen
zutaten vorbereiten ich mache jetzt eine
selbstgemachte soße natürlich eine
hamburger soße und ich werden noch ein
bisschen rote beete und käse mit rein
gehen zuerst nehme ich jetzt das eigene
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen tabasco dazu
ihr könnt auch gerne ein bisschen medica
nehmen da war es gehört eine richtig
schöne und so ein bisschen säuerliche
schärfe da noch der halbe drohnen saft
und ihr könnt im prinzip auch schon salz
zucker senf und tomatenmark dazugeben
und jetzt das eigelb erstmal cremig
rühren und hier gebe ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen pfeffer rein und verrührt das
ganze und schmeckt einfach nochmal die
soße ab ob genug zu drohen und saft drin
ist und tabasco und salz und da kann ich
die soße schon mal in den kühlschrank
stellen und in der zeit die rote beete
vorbereiten
jetzt kann ich die kurz schälen da kommt
jetzt das öl mit dazu und jetzt kann ich
die rote beete in die pfanne anbraten
und west ihr dann gleich mit dem
orangensaft abschmecken und dann lasse
ich den 1
verkochen das fenster solange noch
weiter bis der kopf ist da kommt noch
ein bisschen kreuzkümmel rein und etwas
salz und pfeffer jetzt geht es weiter
mit den zwiebeln ich habe jetzt hier
schon mal zwei zwiebeln geschält hier
habe ich etwa 50 gramm mehl und
natürlich die wichtigste zutat der
grillkäse denn ohne grillkäse wäre es
natürlich keinen bedburger ich habe
jetzt hier den gaza krieg ich bin gibt
es einmal in natur in kräuter und chili
und ich werde jetzt gleich einfach alle
drei benutzen und murat darf sondern
einfach probieren am besten schmeckt
schweigen jetzt aber zuerst noch mit der
zwiebel an die könnte jetzt entweder in
feine ringe schneiden oder eben auch in
spiralen und es nämlich einfach immer so
ein nest von gips ins heiße frittierfett
der grillkäse wir dann einfach in die
pfanne gelegt und von beiden seiten etwa
drei bis fünf minuten angebraten
[Musik]
für den hefeteig verwende ich einen
würfel hefe zwei esslöffel warmes wasser
50 gramm zucker 350 gramm milch zwei
eier und 2 eigelbe etwas vanille extrakt
800 bis 850 gramm mehl einen teelöffel
salz und zimt und 70 gramm weiche butter
jetzt ist die hefe aufgegangen und ich
kann den teig fertig stellen
das heißt ich gehe jetzt einfach alle
zutaten rein beim mehl mache ich es
immer so erst mal nur ein bisschen mehr
als die hälfte die eier und das eigelb
habe ich jetzt einfach mein basis donath
rezept genommen und noch mit zimt
verfeinert
heute geht es mehr um die deko und um
die füllung vanille extrakt ist noch
drin und die milch die habe ich bereits
erwärmt dafür könnte nämlich einfach
dass er mein schälchen auf den herd
stellen kurz erwärmen und dann die milch
direkt eingeben dann anschalten
jetzt wird der teig richtig schön
geknetet und ich kann es nach und nach
noch das restliche mehl dazugeben jetzt
auch die mutter mit dazu neben den teig
drauf und formen ist einfach kurz zu
einer kugel
ihr seht auch da geht jetzt nicht mehr
und jetzt weiß ich den teig schon
aufgeben und jetzt überlege ich mir noch
eine füllung denn ich hätte gerne das
daytona ist eine richtig leckere füllung
raum dafür nämlich 250 gramm himbeeren
250 gramm johannisberg
die sind aus dem tiefkühlfach denn jetzt
bekommt man sie einfach nicht mehr
regional und frisch
dann habe ich hier 50 gramm stärke und
100 gramm zucker den zucker den könnt
ihr natürlich auch variieren weniger
oder mehr nehmen je nachdem wie süß
einfach die früchte sind
das gebe ich einfach alle zutaten hier
in den topf und erhitzt das ganze jetzt
erstmal auf niedriger stufe damit die
früchte einfach auch schön auftragen
können
ich nehme ich den teig heraus und kann
auf einen zentimeter stärke ausrollen
stehe ich jetzt hier die donuts aus
zuerst außen und dann innen
[Musik]
die dort sind jetzt aufgegangen und ich
werde jetzt hier in der friteuse
frittieren seht ihr auch alles in meinem
grundrezept video bei 150 bis 160 grad
also wirklich nicht so heiß im kochtopf
könnt ihr auch nehmen aber wirklich
nicht nicht zu heiss einstellen die dort
sind jetzt fertig den restlichen teig
backe ich gerade noch aus so als mini
köpfen und ich lasse sie jetzt hier
abkühlen und west ihr danach dann
befüllen und dekorieren
[Musik]
für den rührteig verwende ich 200 gramm
weiche butter 200 gramm zucker und eine
prise salz 100 gramm marzipanrohmasse
etwas bittermandel as roma 4 eier die
sind zimmer waren 200 gramm mandeln die
werde ich gleich noch einmal 200 gramm
mehl ein päckchen backpulver das in drei
teelöffel und 125 gramm lauwarme milch
die mandeln werde jetzt frei gemacht
wenn ihr die mandeln dann gemahlen habt
könnt ihr bereits den rührteig
herstellen
jetzt einfach die butter mit dem zucker
verrühren prise salz noch dazu es gebe
zum verstärken des amaretto geschmacks
also dass mandl geschmacks noch ein paar
tropfen bittermandel aroma dazu gibt es
hier für etwa zwei bis drei minuten
verrühren oder vier bis fünf bis es eben
schön weiß cremig ist jetzt gehe ich
hier nacheinander die eier dazu immer
einmal eine halbe minute einrühren und
dann erst das nächste
so gewinnt der rührteig und jetzt kommt
alles machen dann bereit
und jetzt wirklich nur noch kurz rühren
sonst wird der teig nämlich speckig die
möglich ist auch lauwarm das mehl dazu
und mandeln und dann kommt er direkt in
den bug kriegen rein
den habe ich bereits auf 24 zentimeter
durchmesser eingestellt und dann so ein
bisschen verteilen und ich streiche den
teig immer gern am rand etwas hoch so
bagdad gleichmäßiger die torte werde ich
mit einer marmelade füllen und einer
kanadische da mache ich jetzt einfach
eine zart beta gamma und zwar dicker
marsch zum befüllen
das heißt 300 gramm sahne und 600 gramm
zucker schokolade die sahne wird jetzt
einmal kurz aufgekocht
dann schalte ich den herd aus und dann
ruhig die schokolade ein
ich nehme hier den kuchen heraus der ist
schön abgekühlt habe ihn direkt im ring
abkühlen lassen zum film schneide ich
den kuchen jetzt mal durch unternehmen
die entweder torten säge oder einfach
eine totenmesse der erste boden kommt
jetzt direkt drauf
jetzt könnt ihr ihn entweder komplett
mit der ghana spielt oder noch eine
marmelade nehmen nämlich die vorlage
jetzt habe ich sie mittlerweile mit
augen
ok jetzt stehe ich hier einmal außen
herum geht es jetzt kurz fest werden und
dann kann ich wieder weiter schneiden
und das gesicht ist natürlich in der
mitte bei der nase am höchsten und geht
dann auch so ein bisschen noch aus
und überall da wo ich markante
gesichtszüge habe schneide ich sie
natürlich ein und die garage nehme ich
jetzt um das ganze dreidimensionale
formen und zu glätten
das heißt ich streiche die immer wieder
aufsetzt bisschen tag drauf schneiders
weg und so entsteht jetzt gleich die
gesichtsform und habe jetzt hier noch
etwas modelle marzipan also dekra
marzipan
da ist jetzt egal welche farbe ihr nehmt
und damit könnt ihr nämlich gesichtszüge
und die nase zum beispiel richtig gut
formen das heißt sie nehmen ein kleines
stück in die hand schau immer wieder auf
die vorlage platziere es dann einfach
mit den händen schön drücken
und jetzt sieht es echt noch etwas
seltsam aus aber gleich mit der von
sandschicht darüber wird gleich gut ok
hättest der sondern dran
ich habe jetzt hier ein bisschen weiß
und grün und ich rolle jetzt in fondant
auf etwas becker stärker aus jetzt nur
übers gesicht legen denn die haare die
werden ja gleich grün
sie schneidet sie am haaransatz entlang
lieber erstmal bisschen mehr drin lassen
als zu viel wegschneiden
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich modelle werkzeug und geht
es hier einfach komplett in die falten
rein wer die nase schön aus modellieren
und da brauchte einfach ein bisschen
geduld aber ihr detaillierter umso
besser stellte kurz zur seite und kann
etwas grün ausrollen zu überlegen und er
von dort lässt sich auch echt gut ziehen
der ist schön elastisch die feinheiten
schneide ich dann mit dem kater weg mit
dem scharfen messer ich glaube sie schon
mal ganz gut aus jetzt kommt noch eine
haarsträhne die hängt ihr ja so ein
bisschen ins gesicht
die fängt hier hinten an konnte ja jetzt
nämlich schwarzem pulver farbe und
satire jetzt damit das gesicht
so gefällt sie mir schon ziemlich gut
das einzige was ich jetzt noch machen
sind die lichtpunkte die mache ich jetzt
mit der zucker schrift in weiß
[Musik]